soit candidat aux présidentielles a
tchernobyl selon les autorités
soviétiques la situation revient à la
normale
le premier ministre monsieur riche
coffre et le numéro deux du parti
monsieur l'igad chefs ont visité le
secteur de la centrale
un haut dirigeant de moscou a estimé
qu'une erreur humaine serait à l'origine
de la catastrophe les américains pour
leur part continuent à demander des
comptes aux soviétiques
le président reagan a lui même accusé
moscou de mépriser les préoccupations de
la communauté internationale
moscou parle de campagne calomnieuse des
pays occidentaux à son égard un espoir
les images que craignent les autorités
soviétiques
elles viennent d'allemagne de l'ouest
tous ces camions arrivant des pays de
l'est ce transportant les produits frais
sont systématiquement contrôlés
si l'on détecte un taux de radioactivité
supérieur à la normale le camion est
décontaminé une fois la frontière passée
pour les responsables soviétiques
l'heure de la contre attaque a sonné
boris eltsine
le chef du parti communiste de moscou
lors d'une interview à la télévision
est-allemande dénonce l'exploitation de
la faire à des fins politiques
ils ajoutent des mesures ont été prises
la radioactivité a diminué mais elle
s'élève toujours à 200 rade par heure la
riposte soviétique passe aussi par la
télévision
au sommaire du journal soviétique hier
soir la fête dans un village de la
banlieue de kiev et les premiers semis
dans un kolkhoze ukrainien
comment croire à une catastrophe
nucléaire à quelques kilomètres de là
le journaliste précise la presse
occidentale diffuse des informations
insultante à propos de tchernobyl et
certains pays rapatrie de façon
spectaculaire leurs concitoyens